so a few weeks ago i announced that i
was going to be doing an nft project for
our graphic novel god's dog
and uh i guess i was kind of surprised
at the reaction super positive extremely
negative and it it
seems to be turning into one of the most
controversial things i've ever done
which is strangely hilarious
but um it gave seems to give an
opportunity to maybe talk a little bit
about the symbolism of nfts which will
end up being something about
understanding a little bit better the
symbolism of the margin the symbolism of
what matsuyr in his book called the
symbolism of time
and so i did call meter and we had a
long conversation on the phone to uh to
try to see how would be the best way to
present this to you and so here is the
result we're going to talk about the
symbolism of nfts
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
so everybody these days is talking about
nfts for good and for ill there's a lot
of buzz around them especially since the
board apiac club which is probably the
most popular nft scheme out there was on
the cover of rolling stone magazine just
a few weeks ago and so everybody's
talking about it and i'm seeing a lot of
people make fun of it saying it's a scam
other people saying no that it's the
future and so you know what is going on
why is this
let's say why what is the big deal and
so
for those of you who don't know what
nfts are they're non-fungible tokens
that is they are basically contracts
uh which declare that you own a digital
property
that's what they are you know and so
they have several uses but for now what
seems to be the main use of the nft is
in the art world so you can buy
a a piece of art a jpeg or
or a video or some sculpture and then
you will have a proof that you bought it
usually those artworks will be sold in
will be sold in very limited amounts
either a one a one print off or maybe
just a few
and so you get this
contract basically that you own the nft
and that you own this digital artwork
the contract is on the blockchain
usually through ethereum but it can be
done through other uh other cryptos and
so your the your ownership of it is
inscribed on the blockchain basically so
you can transact it you can sell the nft
you can buy the nft and there's a market
and if these go up in value sometimes
they don't there's a lot of stuff out
there that doesn't meet that has no
value and there's some things out there
that are insanely valuable you know that
nfts that are worth hundreds of
thousands of dollars
and so
the big problem that people are pointing
to is that there is no direct
relationship between the owning of the
nft and the object that you're owning so
if you buy an nft of a piece of artwork
you own it in the manner that
let's say
not even you own it in the manner that
you have a contract saying you own it
but you don't own the copyright on that
image the artist owns the copyright on
that image so you're not allowed to
let's say print it out in a book and
sell versions of it it's the artist who
has that capacity and because it's a
digital artwork let's say it's a jpeg
then that jpeg can be copied by anybody
can be screen grabbed by anybody and can
be shared online
in the same way that any other jpeg or
any other file is shared
and so this is why people are saying
there's a scam is because
let's say in terms of ontology in terms
of
of just reality
there is no connection between you
saying that you own the thing and you
actually owning the thing so if i if i
buy a car
and then i have a contract which
stipulates me buying a car then i have
the contract which proves that the car
is mine and then i drive the car i use
the car and if someone takes the car
from me then they're stealing
the car but with an nft the problem and
this is why people are saying it's a
scam is that
you it says you own the thing but you
you don't actually own anything in
practice anybody can copy the the jpeg
and share it around and there has been
some funny memes recently about people
getting angry at others you know screen
grabbing their their nfts which this is
the internet folks obviously this is
going to happen and so you most people
just reacted and think that it's
hilarious that that people would be
offended that these uh that these nfts
are getting shared one word or another
other similar things are can be very
annoyed at nfts because it seems to be
doing
what they don't like about the money
system which is that there's no
relationship there's just these these uh
these contracts that are there that have
no connection to actually in reality
owning anything it ends up being a weird
kind of prestige maybe you know this
proof of purchase that is just that just
makes you seem important and or a kind
of
pure speculation on a market that is
seems very absurd to many people because
like i said you actually don't own
anything and so i could make a painting
and i could sell it to someone i could
take a picture of that painting and then
sell it as an nft online
and so
who is like how what does that mean that
you have the nft all right so what is
going on in terms of symbolism so
thinking about nfts can help you
understand a process which is the
process of the separation of heaven and
earth the place where the identity and
the manifestation actually start to pull
apart
and what it is that that means now i've
talked about it in several ways as well
metric talks about it in his book the
language of creation you know i tend to
talk about it in terms of the idea of
the monster for example and so the
monster has a confused identity there's
we struggle to fit an identity on the
phenomena that we're seeing it can also
be
in relationship to something like
the idea of parasites or the idea of the
strange or something which is added on
to something else um matsir talks about
it in a way
that can be very helpful which is the
relationship for example between bread
and yeast
and so
when you're making bread you have the
dough you have the seed
that is
brought together with water into
uh
into some dough and so in order to but
in order to make the bread
rise up what you have to do is you have
to add a little bit of a monster
inside
the bread so you take some live this
living
parasite bug of a yeast and you add it
to the dough in order to make it
uh puff up let's say and so that is the
role of the place where heaven and earth
doesn't fit is that it
it adds a lot of potential you could say
it puffs up your potential it can
it can have both a positive and negative
effect it's a dangerous game to play
when you start to add let's say
parasites to something but at some point
you'll notice that you do it all the
time so for example
if you're eating something let's say you
make some chicken right so the chicken
has a certain flavor but what will you
do you'll add spice to the chicken so
that spice is not the chicken
it's a stranger it's a it's an alien
thing that you're adding to
the
adding to the the
to the chicken in order to increase its
flavor
now adding the spice to the chicken
won't really increase its food
possibilities won't increase the uh the
nourishment that it's going to give you
but it'll increase the flavor okay
um and so you can understand it that way
the idea of like increasing the flavor
and so um
another good example to that is the idea
of adding ornamentation to things and so
you have a a chair and so you'll
decorate the chair now the the
decoration of the chair doesn't add
to
the capacity the chair has to hold you
when you're sitting in it doesn't add to
the solidity of the chair but the
decorative aspect of the chair or the
ornament the adding of something strange
onto the chair like uh like let's say a
motif
or a specific color or a specific thing
that isn't related to the chair-ness of
the chair it will increase the
experience of the chair it will let's
call it this way it'll increase the
glory of the chair
that is probably the best way to
understand it and so
but it doesn't neces it's it's a date
like i said it's a dangerous game to
play and so
the problem the question of nfts helps
us see what in a certain manner has been
happening from a very long time but now
it's happening in an extreme way which
is that
our entire money system is something
about that right it's something about
thinking thinking about let's say a
trade a direct trade between two people
right and so you have this direct uh
trade let's say i have chickens you have
whatever it is you have wood and like we
tried to figure out you know bartering
what the value of one is with the value
of the other in relationship and then we
we create this trade and so what
happened in in the world is that
people created an intermediary step
which was using precious metals and
until then it was all kind of holding
together so we have this precious metal
that we use to trade different things so
that it's easier
it's kind of uh let's say it uh
it lubricates the the transaction makes
it very easier for for things to to kind
of to to move towards each other and so
uh that was already one thing but then
when we started making actual paper
money when we start having promissory
notes where the money the money itself
is nothing
but we add this to the process in order
to increase the possibility of trade
and the the more we increase it
right the more that we
we diminish the relationship between the
the gold or the metal and the promise
and the paper and this more kind of
fluffy
random thing
then we're able to increase the value
that we can access we're actually
puffing up the market so you can see the
way that that that has increased with
time
in terms of in terms of money and so
that is one of the reasons why people
don't like nfts a lot of people that are
really into bitcoin because they see
bitcoin as a solution
to the problem this problem of money
which is that with time what happened is
that people separated value
let's say actual
value of trade they separated that
you know it became disconnected from the
amount of money that kept being you know
uh put into the system so when for
example the us went away from the gold
standard what happened is that it
increased incredibly the amount of
they puffed up the the amount of value
that you were able to access
but it also made
let's say the system
brought the system in a dangerous place
where it became very
it becomes more fragile you know and it
and it's increasingly makes it unrelated
to value so what it's going to happen is
going to move into extremes because it's
not holding together it'll move up and
down in value much more and it will
create cycles of of uh let's say of
crash and boom and bust because it's
disconnected from stability so think
about it as a really as moving into the
waters of chaos the waters of chaos
bring you up and down up and down we
always think that the waters of chaos
are just the breakdown but the waters of
chaos also include this kind of extreme
of of up and down where you have this
these um
this movement from one side to the other
and so this is what it what kind of
happened of course in the monetary
system and people think that bitcoin is
a solution to that now
bitcoin i'm sorry to say the more i hear
about it i do think that it's useful but
it it also is part of this process
because the things we value in the world
are food you know our relationships are
you know let's say
places we can stay experiences these are
the things that have true value for
humans and bitcoin is just another
version of this added process by which
we ultimately can get to the final thing
and a bitcoin is even in a certain
manner because it is
because it it it is let's say it's it's
it's in a digital space it's just
numbers all of this is also why it does
this as well
for the same reason that the boom and
bust economy does this bitcoin does this
because it's disconnected from true
value which is the uh
the things that we we we care about in
the world right we the idea that human
beings should care about bitcoin is
always a secondary thing it's a
secondary thing to to to having you know
a safe place to live in all of these
things that actually make up our lives
now
so what is the the issue with the
the the nft and so the nft does that
also but in in a very also very very
wild way it it tends to it's used it's
doing this on the bitcoin and the crypto
world and it's almost separating it even
more but there's even less of a
relationship between a weird contract
and the ownership of something which is
just doesn't doesn't exist now this
isn't the first time by the way that
this has been tried this has been
experimented with in the art world for
example in the uh
in the uh in the 1960s there's an artist
his name was klein and he was an
experimental conceptual artist and one
of the things he would do is he would
create
contracts with um
with rich people and so they would sign
a contract where klein would just
blow a piece of gold leaf into a river
and then the gold leaf would float down
the river and that person would give the
artist a huge amount of money to do that
and the only thing left from that that
moment was this transaction that it
happened and so the person basically the
the person only had the prestige of
having
bought that transaction and that was the
artwork the artwork was just this this
momentary thing that was incapable that
you were incapable
of grasping and holding on to and so
strangely enough you could think that
the nft is the ultimate version of this
notion in contemporary art that art is
the process that you can't actually own
the object um and so that's an
interesting aspect of the nft as well
and so now if you look at the symbolism
that i've talked about you can
understand
how the the this nft
notion of the separation
of heaven and earth has to do with
monstrosity and it has to do
ultimately with someone like saint
christopher who is the dog-headed saint
who is the the patron saint of travelers
who is the the patron saint you know the
the saint i always call him the patron
of the the patron saint of the end of
the world so there's a relationship
between the two and so what we're trying
to do is we're actually trying to create
a nft project that is taking into
account
playing with this notion of the
separation of heaven and earth and what
that means because one of the things
that happens in the separation of heaven
and earth is that it also reveals
sometimes some of the highest things and
so for example the crown on the king is
also a kind of separation of heaven and
earth because it is this ornament that
is put on top of the king in order to
to signify that that king is bigger like
is more than the normal person in virtue
of
something which is not in their body
which is not let's say attached to them
something which has been added to them
from the outside and so it has to do so
this adding can be can be a kind of
adding of potential which is dangerous
which is kind of this moving into
monstrosity and moving into the
fragility of the the monstrous space but
can also be adding in terms of an adding
of glory that is added above
this definitely has a lot to do with a
lot of my discussion about the
relationship between death and glory the
relationship between the the ornament
below in terms of a kind of crass
ornament and the ornament above in terms
of this higher aspect of reality that is
really like glory and so what we're
trying to do in our project is try to
connect those two together and that's
why
the the the nft project is based on
the idea of secrecy and the idea that in
the
graphic novel that we made there are
certain hidden patterns that are there
that have to do with understanding the
story in a deeper manner so you can read
the story not get them but underlying
that there are certain kind of hidden
patterns that are there which will
continue on in all in the next books and
we'll kind of play out the let's say the
the deeper aspect of the story
and so that is what we're trying to
include in the nft and so the tiers of
the different nft uh that will be
minting will be related to
the the the revelation of these hinting
at these secrets and so the each tier
will have an each higher tier will have
an extra page that will hint at these
different mysteries now
just because someone buys the nft
doesn't mean they'll understand the hint
and so they'll be in the idea will be to
play with that notion of ownership of
secret and of sharing because if you buy
the nft and then you get the hint
but you don't understand symbolism well
enough to understand it
you might be tempted to want to share
what you get because the downloadable
will be will be accessible to you only
but obviously you can screen grab it you
can share it you can do
all kinds of things with it that you
want to that you want that you decide to
do realizing that if you share it you
might be reducing its value
or you might be increasing its value
it'll be hard to tell in this kind of uh
in this kind of wavy wavy world what
it'll do
and so the tiers will have uh
the the lowest here will be which we
won't have any secrets it will be 40
nfts the second tier will have 20 the
third will have 10 5 and then two and
the very top tier will be the most uh
precious secret because what it what
will be in the top two nfts will be an
actual extra page
an extra comic book page a story page
which will reveal a secret which will
start to appear clear and clear as the
books continue
but once again just because you buy it
just because you see it doesn't mean
that you'll get it that you'll get the
hint and so even at the top tier that's
why you wanted the top tier to have two
is that you'll always know that there's
someone else who has it as well
and
one of you might be tempted to share it
and whoever shares it of course will be
a hero to the others in that are
interested in this uh but then that
might reduce the value who knows we will
figure it out and so that's what we're
trying to play with in terms of the nft
and what we're hoping to do is of course
try to show
participate in how this type of project
is there to inflate you know the whole
thing you know inflate it in terms of
let's say attention that is getting more
people to pay attention to this book
that we're doing but also inflated in
terms of course of the money we're able
to gather because like i've said several
times i'm not taking any profit from
this first book i want to gather as much
as i can in order to assure that we can
just make all the next books without
having to resort too much to
outside funds let's say and so it is
also a way to kind of inflate it in that
way in a way that others can participate
in because
because obviously if we do this in this
book and then we do it for the second
book and the third book and the fourth
book
each time we we
we do a new nft project then the ones
before it will
probably go up in value as well and so
uh so that's the idea that's why we want
to explore the nfts with this project
because this story is about
a dog-headed saint and is about the edge
of the world and the moment when earth
and heaven start to separate what can
that mean what can that mean in terms of
danger
but what can that also mean in terms of
opportunity and so i hope this was
helpful to kind of understand a little
bit the symbolism of nfts i know people
have crazy
like uh
have a lot of ideas and a lot of uh
are stakeholders in this and have strong
opinions and so uh yeah go wild in the
comments and uh we'll see what people
think of my and matthieu's
interpretation of this so thanks
everybody for your attention there's
still a few weeks to back the gods dog
project if you're interested uh go into
that and uh if you're interested in the
nft project you have to
you have to uh you have to send me an
email somehow or
because because we're doing it a little
more in a closed space that that will
inc include a discord server and so
thanks everybody for your attention and
i will talk to you very soon